hey guys welcome to the drunk dunk
challenge now on this one we got drunk
goggles right here and we've set up a
mini obstacle course so sup here's
here's what's gonna happen
we are gonna put on these and then we're
gonna go over there we're gonna get spun
five times by one of our teammates and
then we're gonna have to run this
serpentine course which I can't see very
well cuz I got the goggles on there will
be a ball right here waiting for us that
we have to pick up and then throw into
that target but here's where it gets
tricky
if we miss we gotta go all the way back
to the beginning and keep doing it over
and over and over again until we get it
in there or three minutes three minutes
is up thirty minutes
sounds good well I get to be like a long
time we're not ten tend to start five
after I were you are you I'm ready to
spin I never walk eat croucher I don't
know bookstand oh man have you read okay
read what anyway two one go one watch us
- jeez 301 for your hands go four five
six one down seven
don't kiss me hey he blows nine ten yes
okay wait we work bad I got a ribbon
again like it's off your feet are you
gonna study was three four fire
in 50 seconds what the hell
two three four five no okay
there's also called the mark Juke
challenge huh okay okay I can't look
like it was close uh-huh you've got a
minute 45 left oh gee that's a workout
okay whoa okay okay shut up so tired
okay let's just say two minutes about
this two minutes yeah you got 20 seconds
left we're going to minute oh my toes
yeah
so watch I'm so yeah you got a minute
left
two minutes do anything funny we're just
gonna make it two minutes so we don't
throw up who's it Oh Oh
sweep groan oh my god all right you're
on the darkness so hard I'll go next
you guys don't know I'm still hard
three two one go
spin a mile away from the to don't agree
whoa don't hit the you gotta know this
game and just method I thought you're so
two three four five six what the
obstacle course
hey you got a serpentine it done you got
to go through these things like the dogs
no no no you go back go back
you can fight over the cones bro go back
mmm lesson one two three four cheese
five go for it go don't let your toys
dude now you hit it over okay sorry
display oh geez
wait wait go wow we'll get it on one go
again
- up my toes one two three oh my god
go
okay I got this I got this you're
terribly do bad now I have luck
you got 30 seconds up that's fun
eat more every single one three q1 yeah
let's keep you in a box to do three four
five
except feel six six new this way give it
this way give it this way seven seven
seven seven eight nine or ten I go nope
not that way whoa
we're gonna happen to have a peach
Wow no I got
two three four what
Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go Go football
move go whoo no no switch cold trace for
21:42 nine - that's spin ten go you're
good
all right go form in serpentine Oh bad
I don't know you will ah why are you
gotta you guys you got it there's
literally nothing gold my balance
Wow way back get back get back back back
I hit it go by I'm just picking gear one
man one two three four five six
he keeps wanting to do a bonus when he's
an overachiever we can all appreciate
that okay that's the technique I was
using
oh why are you holding on I need her I
jumped out as soon as it happened like
I'm scared alright alright alright guys
so that was the drunk dunk challenge row
:
that was insane we couldn't see a
goddamn thing and it was a lot of fun so
hope you enjoyed it if you want to see
more stuff we've made a bunch of stuff
on their Channel and old challenges in
the past so check the links in the
description you'll find all them and
check out team edges other videos they
make tons of them like three week maybe
moving forward yeah baby baby I heard
fun so thanks again and as always we'll
see you in the next video bye bye
peace thank you I still feel sick
alright really I feel great